we had people falling in love hospital
one person in love I do love Colton and
the idea of love being dashed against
the rooks like a wave crashing and
sinking all of our hopes and dreams to
the depths of the ocean it's time for
roses and rosy hometowns you guys I'm
Lauren Zima thank you so much for being
here see how I just threw that blanket I
was throwing it just like Colton threw
away someone who was in love with him
yes we are gonna get into it sorry for
the spoiler alert but I'll explain it
all
so hometowns everybody that's what we
have this week with tisha with Kailyn
with Cassie and with Hanna ji not be
she's gone yes you love you gonna be
anyway so hometowns I realized are kind
of like status updates we're checking in
with each couple the bachelors
relationship with each person how strong
all the feelings are finding out if
meeting the families can verify the
feelings and you know hometowns are a
little less about the woman-to-woman
drama cuz the women are all separate
from each other so they're like a little
classier it's like a more elegant affair
like you're meeting the parents and
that's why I'm wearing this jumpsuit
give it a classy now conversely it's
national margarita day so I have a
pretty ratchet margarita that I mean
pretty quick there's lime all over the
side of the glass and then my lime fell
into the glass so nothing classy about
this also don't look at my nails I
really need to get them done so on brand
elevated ratchet that's what we're
working with and I had to celebrate that
it had been national margarita day
because you guys kind of called me out
for letting everybody down I did not
celebrate national white day and look
there's one thing that I love after wine
it's tequila so I wasn't gonna let this
slip
I've default on my face probably what is
you guys's favorite the hard liquor
drink what a question please drink
responsibly
[Music]
hometowns we're gonna be demure and meet
everybody's families but we better start
off with a shower scene I love this I
think we got a new shower this time you
guys we've seen a lot of Coleman what
looked like the shower at the hotel
where he stays the beginning a bachelor
I think they've reused that footage
really breeze this outdoor shower
footage in a variety of locations but
this time we got a new shower and they
really dug in on this new shower we got
a lot of footage we cut to Colton's
feets we cut to him slowly rubbing his
chest
you know let's put it on slo-mo if we
can let's just really really let it sink
in you know and I'm glad we got to see
Cole his whole beauty routine we saw
where he spritzes his Cologne I don't
know why on his pecs on his t-shirt of
his pecs is that I mean I put cologne on
the skin but whatever is great we love
it because things are gonna get intense
after this first up Kailyn Kailyn lives
in oh I think it was called Franken
Fredericksburg in Virginia Virginia oh
great you know she kept saying it was a
cute little town but I gotta be honest I
was bored of this tour of the town of
Franken Frederick's ville cute little
towns are you know they don't have a lot
going on we're in this carriage and
she's giving Colton a tour but she's
pointing out such things as my mommy
said job people's blood
for a living and she store care and then
we got what looked like some pretty
mediocre soft-serve ice cream and it's
also cold out so I don't I didn't
understand the tour or the stops on the
tour and I wasn't here for the tour and
I don't know why two women were driving
the carriage did we need to I don't know
I have a lot of questions but also I
didn't care about the answers on this
one
today's gonna be super special and then
we've got a drink every time Kalyan says
that today is gonna be special super
special but was it special I don't I
didn't even know where you got your
blood drawn I don't like getting my
blood drawn I have to look away very
uncomfortable one time I passed out from
a finger prick okay anyway what are your
deepest fears big questions today guys
big problematic questions so they enter
Kalin's family home through the world's
smallest doorway and you know the lead
always brings flowers and I have an
issue with this and let me know what you
guys do when you bring us something to
someone's house like to a party or
something I always bring a candle I love
candles I spend a lot of time in the
candle aisle at Marshall's I smell them
all I like to pick a candle that's well
price smells great and it looks
beautiful I don't like candles that have
words and brands on the side just a
beautiful candle holder and the reason I
bring a candle is because to me that
Kendall is very useful you can have it
for a long time but flowers especially
when they're in that bouquet it's like I
gotta go put them in a vase I gotta find
a vase I got a cut on I gotta put the
feet in I gotta put the water in the
water ken did you have to : butter I got
a phone again so they last for longer
like I'm not into it you know what are
you great let me know that was Rams ok
she's actually talking you need more
things about me for my own
made me a better person next up
Kaitlyn's dad oh my gosh I love Kalin's
dad John what did you guys think of
Kalin's family I loved the data in
particular he was so sweet
said the most adorable thing about how
being a father to Cailin made him a
better person
oh I love that and you know I do think
that speaks to Cailin as a person I like
Cailin and I like that she makes her
family better like great but I don't
know where this is going she makes me
feel comfortable all these things that
you spoke about that sounds more like
you can just be friends
feelings dad cracked me up so gheylens
dad is asking her how she really knows
but she's into Colton because he says I
think given what she's saying it kind of
sounds like they should just be proud
what's the difference you just be
friends you just bump around together
you know I don't want your heart to get
broken again or is this a possibility
again we all know how this goes Wow okay
and then I wrote down we love John I am
crying because Kaelyn and John have this
conversation where she tells us you have
just an exceptional fight what a father
is my whole life and he tells him he did
everything for her as a father because
it was a reminder he's not her
biological father but he's our dad thank
you for saying yeah and he says thank
you so much for saying that at home I
god I was actually crying were you guys
crying at that moment I was in tears I
was bawling another hard question how
much were you crying or buy okay today
I'm so sorry guys
maybe it's akela takes me to a weird
place so after all that updates on
Kailyn Kailyn has gone from falling in
love to fully in them yeah that is huge
next up Hannah gee not to be confused
with bees and Birmingham with starts
with a beat yes they'll be confused how
do you separate them Hannah gee doesn't
have an accent I couldn't figure this
out I've sort of forgotten that Hannah G
was from Birmingham but Hannah be at
such a thick accent yeah Annie energy
doesn't have a single I can't wait to
show you what the south is olive how
long did you train it out of herself I
don't know anywho so drink every time
Colton bites his lip I don't know why he
does that it's kind of his cute he's
like how sexy did I just like never been
better got some big Texas hair today
higher the hair the closer to God
hmm the more the tequila the closer to
before and the first thing we're gonna
do is say grace I love this etiquette
coach though I kind of wish she hadn't
perfect sin it just would have been
funnier when she's told him
bless your heart bless your heart mmm
that's a southern phrase that means you
idiot bless your heart
mm-hmm your little dumb dumb little dumb
down bless your heart
um there is a proper way to eat your
bread so she told him that because he
didn't know how to rip his bread apart
right I mean drink every time that there
was like unexpected bread drama that was
quite a saga the bread I'm not sure we
needed to devote all of those moments to
the bread and you wanna butter that one
bite of bread
and you want to eat that one bite of
bread mmm buddy of bread any way you
want how do you guy I'm not gonna ask
you how you eat your bread I don't care
I just get as much butter as possible
all I know is just eat the food we don't
care eat your bread the way you want be
free of the constraints of bread 'ok it
this time oh my gosh cool redeemed
himself they go to Hannah G's house and
he brings the flowers in our face
already has that taken their flowers to
someone in the base already just put it
on your table just to enjoy yourself
just focus on drinking your tequila it's
really an honor to meet everybody who
has impacted Hannah she's somebody who's
very special to me I was on shears to
Colton for giving an excellent toast
I mean toasts have been quite a source
of drama this season Hannah beef a
Colton gave a great toast to Hannah's
family I thought loved Hannah's mom Beth
and she talks to her mom and don't drink
every time Beth touches her hair mmm
she's like this man come to taint my
daughter
don't tell me Jesus with her like
vintage glasses and her hoops
I loved Beth big fan of Beth what did
you guys think of Beth all the best of
us what a queen also had some pop and
highlighter on the side that Beth so did
Hannah we were like cutting back and
force them it was like a highlighter
highlighter highlighter
the higher the highlighter the closer to
God
[Music]
it's family the south what am i acting
like I'll be honest the south is it
Oh geographies hard this is what I've
been wanting for you you're a homebody
then oh my god Hannah and her mom were
crying and I love no she told her you
don't get a girl you go get it girl you
don't get a girl back to steal back no
leaves again any kind of grew on me and
now I love him you made a very good cat
Sheldon you don't get a girl
Hannah's mom has an accent though so
weird
I'm Hospital update Hannah G and Colton
are not fully but are falling in love
not fully but falling that's the update
okay status updates then we have
Taoiseach in Santa Ana California I'm
finding yeah oh boy so tisha blindfolds
Colton and then puts him in a car and I
loved everything about this car ride
they're eventually gonna go skydiving
but I sort of enjoyed the car ride more
because first Colton's getting in the
carnies like is this a car boys it's a
car
[Applause]
and then tisha God lover
almost kills him whacks him against the
door
she's weaving in and out of lanes what a
car ride this was the most dramatic car
ride ever in the history of the show
hilarious but then they go skydiving
after these two already bungee jump
together
what crazy dangerous thing are they
gonna do next maybe get engaged that's
good you said you hated height I just
want a spot like Colton's face on the
plane because he was like I mean he
looked terrified I have to say Colt
Fantasia have really good dates together
what do you guys think of Colton tatius
relationship like to me they've done
these extreme things like bungee jumping
and skydiving which bond them but then
they also have that super normal date
that I loved with all the wine and
snacks except it didn't like the cooking
and so they've experienced a lot of
different facets together and I think
that it is really bonding them they seem
to have a really good connection God
please let me survive this fall I still
have to lose my virginity I love it they
cut in audio of him saying he was afraid
to die because quote I still have to
lose my virginity
oh my god what a scream right I want to
give a shout-out to tisha as a little
brother Brice who has some minimal but
meaningful moments in this episode in
the beginning he just kind of gives one
sentence of commentary yeah he wants the
sister be happy then in the middle of
the dinner you know he doesn't really
get to talk we just see him drinking his
lemonade just keep drinking your
lemonade brace your listener I see that
about you you're taking it all and I am
falling in love with her you really say
you're following in love with her then
we have tshis dad and although he does
not like that Colton tells him that he
is falling in love with Taoiseach I mean
that's it that's a strong word it is he
is not into Colton using that word don't
drink every time he says word word it's
a very strong word default word of
saying words
now you're just creating a web if you
will it means house Colton he is in
danger of weaving a web weaving a web
with the word a web of words web if you
will maybe of Lies but update no
blessing from tatius dad I just met you
you know what I mean yeah so we got a
blessing for a proposal from Kalin's dad
a blessing for a proposal from Hannah's
dad but Tisha's dad said no oh wait a
minute that he changes it yeah I think
you're in a good spot so I am content
with saying yes to Colton teach his dad
mint oxidation and he does get the
blessing don't drink for every blessing
so another update that's the status
update stasia's dad gave the blessing
and tisha and Colton are falling but not
fully in love falling but not fully
great because again the show added the
construct that you tell someone you're
falling in love
again speaking to Taoiseach and clothes
connection I mean at the end here do not
drink every time cold one and one more
kiss from tape shop last it's Cassie and
she's in Huntington Beach California and
they try surfing of that is another
nightmare of mine I don't like the ocean
I can't see what's around me under me
coming at me from any which way I think
I saw jaws up too young of an age during
a storm it was traumatic I'm very afraid
of sharks it doesn't make sense I grew
up in a landlocked state anyway Cassie I
admired how honest she was about her
feelings for Colton that she did not
want to tell him something she didn't
mean what do you guys think of Cassie's
feeling did you and preach did you
appreciate how real she was being or did
you wonder Colton why are you into her
when she is not giving you that
reassurance
we go meet Cassie's family and do not
drink every time you hear a high-pitched
squeal and oh my gosh Cassie's dad or
did you think he was the toughest cookie
of the episode I thought so that's why
they saved him for last he did not like
the PDA he did not like that Colton had
his hands on Cassie mm-hmm my favorite
part he calls Colton and I quote a guy
seems like seems like a guy whoa the
shave the tea from Cassie's dad I am
under a shadow the tea is piping hot I'm
drinking it to try to stay warm from the
coolness of the shade wow he is not
messing around
it's weird how well we match together
but that doesn't minimize the fact that
he's meeting three other families but at
the same time what you do like never get
kind of a confusing but tense
conversation between Cassie and her dad
I'm not sure that I walked away with a
takeaway or that she really got anything
from it it was just some back-and-forth
thing but this dad he's the only one he
did not give his blessing No Oh what did
you guys think you didn't get it I don't
know that it matters that much honestly
I think it's an old fashioned thing to
do I don't need anyone to ask for me you
know I don't know what do you guys think
it's not important to you let me know
whenever on which I just don't care okay
update cassie is not fully nor falling
in love with Colton at the end of their
hometown Colton asked her where she's at
and she just says I'm excited for what's
to come
so I'm now wondering what will he
- I don't know why I went around the
world on that well why because we've
been around the world we're back to
hometowns and I am confused at this
moment did you guys have any concept of
which way Colton would go okay I'll be
honest I did think to myself he really
digs Cassie even though she didn't tell
him she was falling in love with him I
feel like he's gonna keep her around
because there is something to playing
hard-to-get I think that a lot of the
time people want what they can't have
and then Cassie being so elusive with
Kolb's maybe keeping you intrigued and
he does also really care about her and
she seems saying that person so or is
really thinking she was so gonna stick
around doesn't happen often in toast I
got to embrace it okay so we are at the
rose ceremony everyone is looking great
but everyone is nervous and I really
like this venue that they're at but
we're not gonna be here long as there's
not many women left we'll Cassie want to
adjust her update I really hope I didn't
mess it up last night
does it know exactly how I feel about
him that's what I wondered would she go
for a Hail Mary tell : hey can I talk to
you for a second I need to tell you you
tell you something I sure told you the
other day with you I just want to tell
you that she didn't dang Cassie standing
strong in her mindset what is my mindset
national margarita day
so the rose ceremony is happening and
our sister wives Kalyn and Cassie are
holding hands and oh my god goodbye
Caitlyn update golden sent Kalyn home
update update : just sent on the one
woman who said she was in love with him
and oh my god Kalin's phase she was like
I thought she was gonna explode
don't look you we love you so she turns
to her sister wife Cassie and says
I love you boyfriend get engaged did she
even say bye to the other women what a
collection of sentences those three
little hummus I love you
boyfriend get engaged it just really
struck me it wasn't exactly poetry so
Kalyn is understandably as she tells
colton and this is the second time cold
and has blindsided somebody but that's
gonna happen when the relationships are
getting real and oh my god update we are
crying on a bed oh this is so hard so
hard how hard was this for you guys to
watch did you think cool and should have
sent Kalyn home oh and then we're in the
car and this is when I'm already
starting to feel like Kalyn come on just
pick yourself up you know she's talking
about how she always is unlucky in love
and will she ever find someone baby or
23 you haven't even had time to be
unlucky in love yet it's okay none of
those relationships matter you've got a
lot of moments out of you move forward
goodbye the world is your oyster Kalyn
you've got a lot of updates in the
future Kalyn fantasy suites are used to
be intimate with one another
the fact that Colton is a virgin next we
can make it or break it we rapped down
this episode talking about how the next
update we're gonna get his fantasy soul
weeds and I kind of forgot honestly that
like Colton was a virgin we haven't
talked about it in a minute
and I sort of laid on it but now fantasy
suites are gonna happen and whoa things
are gonna get super hot I'm like ready
let's go he is ready and whoa Cassie is
having a hot flash about fantasy suites
fantasy suites at a time where
[Music]
speaking of fantasy suites guys as a
reminder we did a roses and Rose a on
The Bachelor franchises sexiest moments
ever if you are dressed a chorus of a
glass and enjoy of that shameless blog
Oh in almost like tequila abstract shape
I love you guys so much thank you as
always for watching I see you I really
appreciated how many of you loved a JC
and I his little wine fight last week I
wine fight wand fight oh my god but that
is the pose on-brand verbal mishap to
make I didn't have any type of insanity
to incorporate JC into this week but I
just wanted to show you guys how I'll
dress C is can you come on camera please
he looked so dapper and sometimes you
know just like all you need is this is a
shower scene sometimes all you need is a
JC and a suit scene oh and he's holding
a coffee Wow la rose' oh look at this
guy very dapper you know what let's take
a poll from the people do you guys like
JC's hair butter downer and a man bun
tough call looking great that's it just
wanted to put a spotlight on him guys
thank you so much okay bye thank you so
much for watching we love hearing from
you leave your comments and questions
below we are winding down who do you
think Colton will pick do you think he
should have sent home Kalyan we have
Taoiseach Cassie and Hanna ji left woo
let us know
now at the end here I have to talk about
the topic that's really on everybody's
mind Bradley and Gaga at the Oscars you
guys it was dark
cinematic twisted violent unacceptable
emotional sexual dynamic everything
beyond all we wanted it was Jackson and
Ali Ali's best at the piano and Jackson
wasn't doing super great until he walked
over and sat beside her
did I think they were gonna maybe make
out yes
would it have been in character yeah at
the end of the day what I'm really
mourning now is the loss of the shallow
journey the most dramatic award season
ever I fell in love with Bradley and
Gaga but I don't know that they fell in
love with each other
so nobody gets a love en Rose a side
note all my love - Hanna G that I could
not sit through that beatboxing I fast
forward it